bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors la revalorisation
concerne exactement 227 mille
agriculteurs est ce que c'est trop peu
selon vous non seulement 4 op je pense
que le chiffre de 227 lille est
surestimé les indications que j'ai moi
cela plutôt que 190 villes du fait de
l'écrêtement qui a été ôtée en même
temps que la loi chassaigne voté par une
majorité l'a déplacé à les réaliser
alors que d'une part c'est peu
d'agriculteurs par rapport au million
deux cent mille retraités agriculteurs
agricultrices bien sûr et c'est surtout
limiter ou chef d'exploitation donc sont
exclus de cette revalorisation qui était
attendue depuis je pense ou presque
presque une vingtaine d'années qui a été
différée il ya trois ans par le
gouvernement
cette opération concerne donc uniquement
le chef d'exploitation et les bienvenus
évidemment n'est pas suffisante
sans doute mais surtout c'est laisse de
côté une grande partie de l
travailleuses et travailleurs de
l'agriculture qui ont le statut de
conjoint collaborateur d'être familiaux
des statuts qui n'ouvrent pas droit
cette revalorisation justement
christiane lambert la président de la
fnsea affirme que cela ne leur est pas
la question vous êtes le dire des
retraites des conjoints en des chefs
d'exploitation qu attendez vous à ce
niveau là il me semble que les
discussions sont encore en cours
aujourd'hui c'est la consécration des 85
% pour les chefs d'exploitation
il n'empêche que notamment andré
chassaigne et d'autres parlementaires
madame dubois madame vous
ont des projets de loi en cours pour
récupérer disons c'est récupérer ouvrir
cette revalorisation au conjoint aux
aides familiaux conjoint conjointe aides
familiaux et également les personnes qui
ont dû cesser leur activité pour pour
cause de maladie ou de handicap alors
cdc les projets qui sont en cours et que
nous espérons voir aboutir rapidement
parce que c'est vraiment quelque part
c'est les plus démunis qui aujourd'hui
doit encore regarde passer le train sans
savoir monter dans les wagons votre
sentiment également quant aux
agriculteurs français qui dénonce une
mauvaise répartition des aides de la pac
c'est un autre sujet en tant que l'autre
était effectivement jeu on a une
philosophie de d'attac très économique
pas du tout social pas du tout
écologique pas du tout en rapport avec
les enjeux du moment notamment la
biodiversité les changements climatiques
et tout et c'est cette recette pas qu
elle ne peut pas continuer comme ça
c'est pas possible que qu'elle reste sur
des bases essentiellement économique
il faut qu'elle prenne en compte la
partie le domaine social domaine
environnemental va tout et il ya des
possibilités la france n'utilise même
pas toutes les possibilités qui sont
offertes notamment en direction des
petites fermes est différente et les
activités qui sont écartés pour
l'instant des bénéfices de l'attak
je pense aux maraîchers other droits
culturels toutes ces productions andré
tissot merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct ça sur rt franc je rappelle que
cet agriculteur à la retraite marcia fou